The easiest way to lose in life is to
try to avoid looking bad. So you have to
stop caring about what other people
think of you. I'm Alex Shamuzzi. I own
acquisition.com. It's a portfolio
companies that generate last year over
250 million in aggregate revenue. Along
the way, I've had to work and push
through a lot of things that other
people disagree with. I had to lose
friends along the way, people who didn't
agree or approve of my lifestyle, family
as well. And so this video is just going
out to anyone that resonates with that
or you're in a period of life where you
know you need to separate from the pack
in order to create the new pack that you
want to be a part of. And so what I want
to do is give you some reframes on how
to change your perspective on how other
people see and think of you. That won't
necessarily make it easier to not care
about what they think, but more so still
allow you to operate anyways because at
the end of the day, the work just needs
doing. And so number one, ignore the
opinions of losers. So hear me out.
Richer people won't judge you for saving
your money. Fitter people won't judge
you for cutting calories or packing your
food or deciding to eat a certain way.
Right? Higher status people aren't going
to judge you for cutting bad friends.
It's the people going nowhere who have
the most to say because they have
nothing to do. And so take the fact that
they have something to say as an
indication that they're not doing
anything else with their time. Not that
it's some sort of sign that you need to
change your life or change direction.
You're probably on the right path. They
are leading indicators. Their hate,
their snide remarks, the little like
you're missing this, you're not doing
that. Those are actually positive
indicators despite the fact they hurt
because you're kind of still
transitioning your programming from the
way that you used to be to the way that
you want to be. And so if you're trying
to be successful and you're facing big
life decisions, don't listen to the
people closest to you. Listen to the
people who are closest to your goals.
And I think that if you are in a
situation where there's no one around
you who's closest to your goals, then it
means that you're going to have to
consume information from the outside.
It's almost like you have to separate
your brain from your body. You need all
your consumption of information to be
from people who are where you want to
be. And you can have your body for now
in a place where it doesn't want to be.
But in time, once your reality catches
up, you can actually move your body to a
place that now makes it even easier for
you to consume the things that you need
to get to where you want to go. And so
fundamentally, if you don't want
someone's life, don't take their advice.
If you don't like the way they live, if
you wouldn't swap places with them, if
you don't like the way they have a
relationship with their wife or their
girlfriend, or you don't like how they
think about work or you don't like how
if they're, you know, not in shape,
they're not in any of the you don't envy
them in any domain, why would you value
their advice? And if you think this is
something that I'm saying because I'm
trying to do from a pedestal, like I
promise you, like I gain nothing from
these videos, like and if you're like,
why does Alex even bother making these
videos rather than just like all the
business stuff that I normally talk
about? because these these concepts were
the things that laid the foundation for
meble to do the things I had to do in
business if I didn't have this base
level programming. I couldn't do
anything else afterwards. And so I also
don't say this to somebody who didn't go
through that. Like for me the hardest
decision to my whole life, the hardest
decision that I ever had to go through
was quitting my job. And it sounds like
such a basic thing, but for me the job
that I had had was basically the
culmination of everything that I had
done at that point. Like I was caring
about what college I was going to go to
in middle school. I know that's very
hard for some people to grasp because
that's like not your reality, but for me
that was reality. I remember thinking,
are they going to look at my eighth
grade transcripts? Like I didn't know.
And to be fair, I was a little bit lied
to by my parents, but like we'll just
leave it like that, right? And so when I
went to high school, like the
extracurriculars that I took, the fact a
three sport varsity athlete, the fact
that I wanted to become the literary
magazine editor and chief for my high
school and vice editor of the newspaper,
like I did all that stuff because I
wanted to get to college. Then when I
went, you know, studied for the SD, I
got into Vanderbilt. And then when I
went to Vanderbilt, I graduated in three
years because I was like, if I do that,
and while I was there, I was vice
president of the power of the team and
president of my fraternity. And like
while I was there, I was like, "Okay, if
I max this this transcript, maybe just
maybe I'll get a great job." And I did
get a good job out of college. I had a
white collar consulting job, which is
kind of like one of the you either go
investment banker consulting at the high
echelon schools. And so like this job
was the culmination of everything that I
had done in my life at that point. And
here's the part that really sucked is
that like for me, my dad was really
happy with my life. He and I would get
lunch a couple times a week. He would
just like he would, you know, brag
about, you know, his son who's the
businessman. I was working. I was a
consultant. I was a businessman. It's
He's like, "You're following the plan."
He's like, "You do this for a few years.
You go back to business school, get your
MBA, you do the next thing, right?" And
so, it was always the next thing. The
thing is is that it was this, it was a
path. And I knew that me getting off of
it literally meant that I had to forsake
basically all the friends that I had
locally in Baltimore cuz I came back
home. second because all the guys that I
knew who followed the same path, me
stepping off that path is almost me.
It's like unspoken talking about the
path that they're still following. And I
think that's the really nasty one is
that if you start doing something
different than everyone else is doing,
they assume that you're attacking them
for living their lives out. I don't know
why people do this, but they do it. And
so a lot of ways they want you to fail
because they want confirmation that the
path that they're on is the right path.
and they want you to fail with the risk
that you choose to take because it
confirms the fact that they that they
shouldn't take the risk that they
weren't willing to take. And so don't be
upset when people have these snide
remarks. It's because they're actually
protecting their own egos. It took me a
lot longer to figure that out. And so
just reminding myself that like, hey,
I've been able to boil down almost all
criticism from other people in my life
to this statement. So please listen to
it carefully. You do not live in a way
that I would prefer. That's all it is.
Every single remark, why are you doing
this? Blah blah blah. It just comes down
to you live your life in a way that I
wouldn't prefer. And the answer to that
is of course not cuz it's my life. You
should live your life in the way that
you prefer. Why should I live my life in
the way that you prefer? That makes no
sense. But when as soon as I I got that
translation, that reframe, it somehow
just like it it was like the volume of
the world turned down for me. Oh, okay.
Why aren't you going to be at this guy's
the the fantasy football thing? Why
aren't you go to this destination? Why?
I was like, dude, I'm trying to save
money. I don't like I can't afford that
in time. I can't afford that with money,
you know? And that's why I'm like I got
some flack, you know, online where I was
like, "Hey, I didn't go to a lot of
friends weddings when I was in my 20s."
They're like, "These are once once in a
lifetime thing." Hey, first off, half
divorced. Second off, the thing is is
like if they're real friends, like real
real friends, couple things. One, if
they're real real friends, they won't
care because you're actually real
friends. Second, if they're real real
friends, you probably only have like two
of them, like real friends. If you're
like, "No, I've got like 40 friends."
Like you don't have like you have
acquaintances, you have people you've
met who invite you to pay money to come
to their thing, their party. It's just a
party. It's all it is, right? Obviously,
for those of you religious, whatever,
there's that attitude, don't get me
wrong. But even so, your attendance does
not in any way impact the quality of
their marriage. It also doesn't really
impact the quality of their friendship.
And if your friendship is lost, a
lifetime of friendship is lost over your
attendance over a party, then you're
probably it's probably not a friendship
worth keeping. And so, that was always
my perspective. Two of the closest
friends I had, I actually couldn't is so
crazy. Two of the weddings that I
probably would have considered going to
during that decade both happened within
the same two weeks. And Leila and I both
got COVID in those two weeks. And so I
actually didn't go to the two weddings I
probably would have gone to. Now guess
what? I'm still friends with both of
them and they don't care. So it's this
idea because when you're a kid or you're
younger these feel like these massive
milestones, but like as you get older
like this stuff just shrinks into
irrelevance. It just doesn't matter. The
things that do matter is that the
relationship you had wasn't going to be
predicated on whether you you attended
something a party. So number two,
extreme people get extreme results. Now
this one's near and dear to my heart. So
I'll tell you why. So my father is a big
believer in astrology. So zodiac stuff.
So my whole upbringing he was like
you're, you know, he had all these book
these big fat books on like what your
life's going to be and all this kind of
stuff. And my dad's a smart guy. He just
likes it. So anyways, I'm a Leo 2 or
three. I think I'm a Leo 3 and he's a
Libra. So Libras are balances. And so I
would say that if there was one thing my
dad repeated to me the most throughout
my entire upbringing, the most the
number one most repeated statement was
balance. He'd always say balance.
Balance. You just say just one word,
balance. Balance. Balance. Cuz he was
like, you're so unbalanced. you're so
extreme. And this one's near and dear to
my heart because I was told my whole
life that I was unbalanced, that I was
too extreme, that I was too hardcore,
that I was too allin, that I was too
obsessive about everything. And I
honestly had to fight to be me. And I'm
making this because it's not common to
be unbalanced. It's more common to be
mediocre. Like the people who obsess
about work life balance tend to be
mediocre at both. And so like if you
want something, you have to go get it.
It's it's like this entropy. Like the
world will try to drag you down and make
you a part of it. It will try to dilute
who you are. It will try to make you fit
into the mold that they accept. And so
like you have to be willing to be
extreme to get an extreme result because
many of the goals and aspirations that
you have probably are above average.
Like actually if you look at you're like
I want to make a million dollars a year.
Fine. Guess how rare that is. You want
to guess? It's not 1%. 1% 600k in the
US. And if you're global, forget about
it. So you want to make a million
dollars a year. That's not even a one
out of a 100red goal. It's a one out of
200, one out of 300 goal. And you have
that goal and you think that somehow
you're going to behave like the 299 and
get there. It's not normal. It's
unbalanced. You have to take
unrelenting, obsessive amounts of action
for a disproportionate period of time
where you get zero reward for doing so.
If anything, you just get
disproportionate punishment for taking
this. And you get and you question your
own sanity half the time because you're
like, "Am I just being crazy? Is it
insane for me to have these aspirations,
these goals, these dreams for my life?"
And everyone around you will tell you
yes. because it's in their best interest
because it makes it your failure
protects their ego. And so people demand
success but refuse to work. Right? They
won't work weekends. People want
opportunity but won't talk to strangers.
People claim ambition but they sleep in
every day. Right? We're the result of
our actions, not our aspirations. So
many people have the same goal as you,
but very few of them will do the same
work as you. And so you have to have
uneven work to have an uneven goal.
Yeah. Broke the leash when I left. That
was like it was [__] My dad was like,
"I'll see you never." So, number three,
and this is a big one, raise your
standards. Now, a lot what's interesting
about standards more than the other
first two things that I just brought up
is that standards actually have to come
down to beliefs of what you think is
possible. And the beliefs of what you
believe are possible create the
construct within which you live your
life. And so, we live inside of prisons
of our own making based on our belief
system. And so, if you want to change
your life, you have to change your
belief system. Now, I'm not getting woo
woo. Calm down. A belief system is just
a different way of saying things that
you know or believe to be true. These
are just the facts that you live on. Now
thing is is we can't double check every
single thing that we believe because we
can't it just it would take too long,
right? As a human being, if you every
single thing you had to fact check. So
the vast majority of the things that we
believe and take as true were just given
to us by other people. It's what I find
very interesting about this is that we
are so hesitant to question our beliefs
when in reality almost none of our
beliefs are our own. They're not yours.
They're someone else's. And so I'll say
something that I can maybe just do my
very best to translate to you. For many
people, working around somebody who's a
super high achiever, a super high
performer shifts their worldview because
they they see a different way of
operating and a lot of it comes down to
what that person demands and expects of
the world and reality. I'll give you an
example. So I'm relatively good friends
with Jimmy, Mr. Beast. Just from happen
stance, we've we've created a a good
friendship. And I've read Elon's
biography by Walter Isacson and Jobs.
Some of the friends that I have that
are, you know, billionaires and whatnot.
They have this streak. And the streak is
a level of unreasonleness around their
goals and what they believe to be
possible that they just do not accept
less. And so Munger said this thing that
I really like a lot, Charlie Mer. He
said, "Never underestimate the man who
overestimates himself." And I think
there's something to that. like he
Charlie Mer hated men who had big egos,
crazy aspirations. He thought it was
really risky, but at the same time he
also said they tend to win. And I think
that there's a huge element of truth.
Like I think many people who know me
would consider me to be one of the most
unreasonable people that they have met.
And it's not like in a way of purposely
trying to be combative with other
people, but more so when you witness
someone say, "Hey, I need this done
tomorrow." And then one by one
disassembling every single person around
them who tells them why it can't be
done. And then once the 20 different
voices you've told them why their idea
can't work and they've just eviscerated
every single one of them. It's like
great. So tomorrow then right it's like
they will stand there. They will take
the brunt of the storm from the whole
army to be like I know this is possible.
Tell me why physically we cannot do
this. If you cannot break it down to
physics then it is possible and we're
going to do it. Tell me what is stopping
us. And then just systematically
destroying every one of these obstacles
to make something that for most people
will seem impossible possible. And so
the thing is is like of the people that
I've seen that have just been absolutely
crazy high performers, they've all been
like this. And so the thing is is that
it's so rare. And so if you have this
drive, this determination, this thing
inside of you're like, why isn't anyone
think this is so important? Like this is
the most important thing, right? And so
there's this great visual that I want to
draw for you real quick. Hopefully I
won't mess up my own little clean clean
slate here, but I'm going to draw for
you cuz I really love this. So Paul
Graham, who's the founder of Y
Combinator, had this little tweet about
this that I really like. And he said,
"If you have intelligence, you know, on
one line here, and then you have
determination on the other line." He
said, "Let's say you've got a 100 points
like you're building a character for a
video game on either side of this line."
He said, "If you take down
determination, you know, one point at a
time and you keep intelligence, pretty
quickly you have this very smart person
who doesn't do anything and convinces
themselves that like nothing nothing
will happen." He said, "But the
interesting thing is that if you keep
taking intelligence down, he said, you
can keep going, but when you have
somebody who's 100 out of a 100red
determined," he's like, "They tend to
just still be very successful." He said
which is why determination even more so
far more so than intelligence is the
determinant of success. And so when they
look at that in Y combinator how do you
operationalize determination? So
determination from a behavior
perspective in my opinion comes down to
the it's it's an extinction curve. All
right. So an extinction curve I'll give
you a simple example. I'll give you two
examples to drive it home. Let's say you
knock on a door right? No one opens or
nothing happens. Right? So that's a null
outcome. You do something nothing
happens. Some people will knock again.
They have a longer extension curve than
somebody only knocks once. Nothing
happen. A smaller percentage, a much
smaller percentage will knock a third
time. Nothing happens. A significantly
smaller percentage will knock a fourth
smaller percentage will knock a fifth
time. And it's the maniacs who will
stand there and then knocking door down
because they believe somebody's on the
other side. And if no one is, then
they'll just pay for get the door fixed
because they were really confident that
there was somebody on the other side.
The thing is is that when you behave
that way in the world, that extinction
curve, that is determination. How many
times can you continue to act without
seeing the results of your action? That
is determination. You want something and
you will just continue to beg. And maybe
it's you knock on the door, then you
jiggle the handle, then you look through
the window, then you go around back.
Like there are so many people that off
the first knock stop. And so I use the
example of just knocking in again and
again. But the reality is that you
typically will knock multiple times,
knock louder, shout, look through the
window, go around back, call the phone,
text, see if there's a find my friends,
text their friend to see where they're
at. Like there's how many doors will you
go through or will you break down to get
what you want. That is determination.
Basically the goal doesn't change. How
you get there you don't care about. You
just care that you get there. And so
that trait above all else and this is
something that I have witnessed with
beast and the few billionaire friends
that I have and just what I've read from
from Elon and you know Steve Jobs is
like the unwillingness to shake from
what they believe to be true. And so the
thing is is that this isn't permission
to act like a dick. But it is permission
to say that if someone can't disprove
why what you think is possible is
possible, that you absolutely can hold
on to that with white knuckles and say
no, we will figure it out and you will
tell me what obstacles are in the way
and one by one we will dismantle them
until all that is left is the goal. And
so here's the tough reality that I had
to realize and I used to repeat this
self. Sometimes other people's dreams
have to die in order for yours to live.
And I remember having to say that to
myself because all it is is that they
have aspirations for my life. I'm never
going to listen to someone whose
aspirations for my life are smaller than
my own. Like don't take advice from
someone who has smaller dreams for you
than you. And so the thing is is that my
dad, believe it or not, because he had
higher fear around risk. And so it
wasn't out of mal inention. It wasn't
out of malice. It wasn't because he
didn't want me successful. He didn't
want me to be a failure more than he
wanted me to be a mega success. Because
if you think about it from a parent's
perspective, you are your parents
biggest burden. I heard this in a little
short the other day. I loved it. You are
your parents biggest burden. You are the
thing they worry about 24 hours a day
all day long. And the thing they're
worried about is that you're going to
make it. And make it for them is just
that you're productive member of
society, that you're happy you could
feed yourself. That's fundamentally what
they want. They want you to have a good
family. They want you to have something
that you don't hate and that you can
make money doing. That's it. That's to
be fair, that's a high bar in some
places. But the thing is is that your
dreams for you might be higher. But if
your dreams are higher, so too might be
the risk you're willing to take. And so
they have a different risk apparatus
than you do. And it makes sense because
for you it's like think about how how
scared they are of you getting hurt of
something bad happening to you. So it
makes sense they act that way. It's not
you doing something dumb. Now don't get
me wrong, you might be doing something
stupid, but the thing is is that the
good news is like unless you die, you
can still get back up and try again. And
so for me, it took me realizing that the
people who were telling me what I need
to do with my life had smaller goals
than me because if I told them what I
really wanted, they'd be like, "Dude,
get real." And so you might have that,
too. Some people in your life may be
like, "Be realistic." It's like, "I'm
not trying to be realistic, man. I got
one life. I'm going to die." And here's
the crazy part is that life is short,
but youth is even shorter. And so, use
it while you got it. So, number five,
and this was this one's uncomfortable.
Pain is a prerequisite to progress. So,
I remember saying something about this a
while back and I had a bunch of comments
that I saw of people being like, "As
soon as this guy said pain is progress,
I was out." And I can already tell you I
know that they're not going to be
successful. And it's not that I'm saying
that like I want you to go through pain.
I don't think anyone wants someone to go
through pain, but I think that you want
someone to grow. And think about the
reason they call them growing pains is
because as soon as you stretch past your
potential, as soon as you get into an
area that you haven't done before, it's
uncomfortable. And so to get the
adaptation from the extra stress, you
have to have the extra stress to get the
adaptation. And so you can beat 99% of
people without being smarter or luckier,
but by being willing to endure pain and
uncertainty. That's a big one,
uncertainty for longer. because the
fastest growth periods are often the
most miserable. And so if you want
progress, get used to pain. And I love
this quote from Paul Graham. I
referenced him earlier, but if you want
to earn a million dollars, you have to
endure a million dollars worth of pain.
And so I said there was two kind of
categories there. One is the actual
pain. And the other is the uncertainty.
But the thing is a lot of the pain comes
from the uncertainty. Like what's
interesting about this is they've done
this little experiment with uh with mice
and I remember reading about this and
being like that makes so much sense. So,
a mouse that gets dropped into water,
right, will do its little mouse paddle,
whatever, and then eventually drown
after like however many, you know,
minutes. If they took that mouse,
drowned it, and then right before it was
about to, you know, die, they uh pulled
it back up, dried it off, and then put
it back in, it went like 30 times
longer. It wasn't even it wasn't like
20% longer, 50%, it was like 30 times
longer. It stayed above because it knew
there was a chance of survival. And so
the first mouse who then gives up at the
30 minute mark rather than like the 60
hour mark or something insane is
everyone because we don't know if we're
going to make it until you make it. You
don't you don't get the second you don't
get the human or whatever who pulls you
out and then puts you back in. You don't
know that. And so you just have to have
faith that if you keep paddling, if you
keep your head above water, you'll
eventually make it to where you're
trying to go. And so it's the
uncertainty that we have to battle. This
is why there's like I do every once in a
while make these types of videos because
like it's the stuff between your ears.
It's the beliefs you have about the
world that ultimately allow you to
persist and continue when things don't
work. Cuz I want to be honest with you,
like 2025 has been by far the hardest
year of my well hardest year in the last
eight years. Out of the last 13, it's my
fifth worst. All right? But out of the
last eight, it's a local minimum. It's
the worst year I've had almost in the
last decade. And I bring this up because
so people have heard of hedonic
adaptation, right? You get used to
pleasure very quickly. What they don't
talk about is that you also get used to
pain. So you habituate. You get used to
things quickly. So it actually does work
on both sides. But here's the nasty
part. The reason entrepreneurship and
growth is so difficult is that you do
not adapt to pain if the pain changes in
intensity or variety. And so if you want
to effectively punish someone, then you
want to change the variety of punishment
and the intensity of punishment. And so
the thing is is that life is exceptional
at doing that for you. And I love this
saying um life doesn't fight fair and
neither does business. And the thing is
is that you have to fight regardless.
You have to fight nonetheless. And you
have to win. And that means that
whatever whatever whatever software you
have to install, whatever belief system
you need to have, you do whatever it
takes. And so, um, I wasn't planning on
sharing this, but I'm going to I'm going
to do it now cuz I think it's I think
it's relevant. So, I just had a a friend
of mine for a long time ago who came out
to visit me. And he had started a
business and it was in an industry that
I know a lot about. And over that time
period, he never once reached out to me
for help or anything closing the
business down. And so when he came out,
I was like, "Dude, what the hell?" And
he said, "If I was going to fail, I
wanted it to be my own. I didn't want it
to be I didn't want anyone else to kind
of like have a part of that. I wanted to
like I wanted to own the outcome
regardless." And I was like like I heard
that and I just thought to myself like
what a terrible way to see the world cuz
my perspective is entirely different
than that. Mine is I want to win no
matter what. And if I need to ask for
help from a hundred different people, it
doesn't matter how many people I help
cuz it is my fault no matter what
whether I win or not. And so it's also
my responsibility to do everything in my
power to win. And so I get no points
from anyone by losing on my own. I get
no points for doing it on my own because
at the end of the day, you're never
going to have done it on your own. You
were born from somebody else. My dad
came here came as an immigrant. So did
my mother, right? Both my parents are
first generation immigrants, not born
here. So like everything I have is
because of them. Okay? I'm also born in
America. I'm a white guy. I've got good
genetics. Whatever. Like there's a
hundred things that are out of my
control. But if you don't play every
card you have, then what are you doing?
And I'll tell you the story that my dad
told me and it was actually like really
impacted me. There was there was a
period of time where I thought like I
came out of academia so I had the the
guilt right the guilt of privilege that
they try and instill in you. What a
handcuff by the way. Anyways so I told
this nonsense to my father and he said
to me do you think Shaquille O'Neal was
like I can't play basketball. I'm 71.
It's not fair to other people for me to
play basketball cuz like this is like
I'm have such an advantage. And he just
looked at me. He's like play the cards
you have. He's like, "You can't play
basketball. You're not 71." He's like,
"But you can do this, so do it." Like,
if you're good at something or you have
some natural predisposition, by all by
every means possible. Knock on every
door. Bang the door down if you have to
get the opportunities that you want to.
Like, what's your downside? Shame. Shame
is your downside. Someone wagging their
finger at you saying you broke a rule
that doesn't exist that I made up to
make you feel bad. You're going to die
and so are they. So get get what you
want. So number six, success demands
courage. So what's interesting is that I
think Peter Thiel said this, or maybe
I'm just making that up, courage is in
far shorter supply than intelligence.
And so a man with twice the courage and
half the advantages will always beat a
man with twice the advantages and half
the courage. There it is. And Peter Seal
said this, "Courage is in far shorter
supply than genius." There's a lot of
really smart people. There aren't a lot
of very courageous people. And he's
talked about this and I agree. There's
an interesting, you know, observation
you can make is like why are there so
many kind of like autistic founders that
build these big companies? And his
thesis, which I agree with, is that many
of them just miss social cues. And so,
because they're less affected by the
social criticism and social rules that
other people choose to adhere to, even
though it's entirely arbitrary and made
up, they're able to operate in a world
without those rules, a world that's
significantly more of their own making.
And so, that's the construct they choose
to live in. And so right now you have
likely the things that are causing you
fear are rules you made up or rules that
other people told you that you chose to
believe. The way that you conquer those
rules or at least the ways that helped
me is playing it out. It's like okay
like fear exists in the vague, not in
the specific. So when someone says I'm
going to be a failure, that's vague.
What does that mean? It means that you
tried something and didn't work. Is that
what you mean? Well, because that
happens all the time, right? It can't be
that. No. What is it? Well, other people
would know what that you tried something
and it didn't work. Okay. Does that mean
that you give up forever? Cuz that would
make you a failure, not just trying
again. Cuz if you kept trying again,
would you still be a failure if you
tried a second time? Well, I guess if I
was still trying. Yeah, you're still
trying. You're still trying. You're not
a failure. You're still trying. Okay.
Well, I What if I lost all my money?
Well, guess what? 60% of America has no
money. Welcome. 60% of America is like
literally less than zero dollars. They
literally have less money than they owe.
But even so, does sleeping on your couch
or living in a worse neighborhood or not
having as good of a car, is that make
you a failure? I think it like it's
still way better than the vast majority
of the rest of the world. And so, like
in the Western or developed world, your
worst case scenario is you get free
housing and free food. That's your worst
case scenario. I think the true downside
is believing their lie and then living
the rest of your life as a slave to
someone else's dreams. Real quick, guys,
I wrote these two books. one will help
you make whatever the thing that you're
selling is better so that you can get
more people to buy it at way higher
prices. And this one is about getting
the world to find out about it, which is
how do you get leads? And these together
can help just about anyone get their
business started or scale their business
from wherever it is to significantly
bigger. I've spent more time on these
books than any piece of content by a
mile. And I think in aggregate they have
like 32,000 five stars on Amazon. And so
if you want them, I'm sure there's a
link somewhere and you can find them on
Amazon, too. And if you're poor and
don't have $20, you can go uh to
acquisition.com/audiobooks and I'll send
you the audio version of this free.
Number seven, be okay with no one
cheering for you. Think of it like this.
No one cheers for you not drinking for a
day or not smoking on a long drive or
not overeing for one night. No single
workout or meal is ever impressive on
its own. The reason so few people
understand success is consistency never
looks impressive in the moment, only at
the end. And so people only root for
people who don't need it once you've
already won. People are like, "He's
amazing. He's so good." But like that's
the last time you need it the least. And
so you're all you always have to be the
person who roots for you before everyone
else does. And people struggle to do
things alone because if everyone else
were cheering you on, then it means that
you're not in the right place. It means
that you're just like everyone else and
that's not where you want to be. You
know, I'll tell I'll tell you a really
interesting one that's more recent. So,
when I was about a year and change out
from selling gym launch, I wanted to
have a second acquisition channel. So,
we ran a lot of paid ads and I wanted to
have another way to get customers. And
so, I read this book on outbound and I
was like, "Okay, we're going to do this
outbound thing." And 90 days in, we had
only done one sale. And I put all my
attention towards this thing. And I
remember the whole executive team like
kind of like called me onto a Zoom call
like an intervention, right? Like all
these people were there and I was like,
whoa, what's going on? And I was like, I
mean, I own the company. I can't get
fired. So, what's going on? Right? And
so, they were like, hey, we need to talk
to you. You're spending way too much
time on this outbound thing. Like, your
focus is needed elsewhere in the
business. Let's do more of what works.
This is a woman in the red dress. I was
like trying to use my stuff against me.
I remember that conversation so vividly
because it had been 90 days and we only
had one sale. I basically had almost
nothing to show for my work, right? And
I remember it so vividly because the
scene that I recall was this moment in
the movie Troy, Brad Pitt. It's an old
movie and it's at the very beginning and
Brad Pitt, who's Achilles, is going to
go fight this giant right before he's
about to, you know, fight the giant.
There's this little boy, it might have
been a squire or something who hands him
a helmet or whatever. And he says, "He's
huge. You know, I wouldn't want to fight
him." And Achilles Brad Pit looks down
at the boy and he says, "And that is why
no one will remember your name." First
off, savage. Second off, I remember
thinking that because like it's normal
to not want to keep moving when no one's
cheering for you. Cuz the reality is
that people only root for other people
at two times. At the beginning when you
start and at the end when you finish.
The problem is neither is when you need
it. So you have to master the middle,
the boring, soulcrushing, unending,
relentless middle. It's the step after
step after step while you're running the
marathon. Like the starting gun's
exciting. It has balloons. Everyone's
there with you and it's like I'm going
to start this thing, right? And then
there's nothing. there's just nothing
for 26 miles. Just nothing. And then at
the very end, you've got more balloons
and more people. But that's where the
winning happens. The winning happens on
your own. So after that little
intervention, I said, "No, we're going
to double down on this because I think
this is what's required for us to be
able to sell this company." And over the
next 9 months, we're able to get piece
by piece by piece to get it to work
until eventually outbound was 50% of our
sales. And because of having two very
different acquisition channels, it made
the business significantly more stable
and ultimately sellable. That decision
to basically tell everybody, "Yeah,
you're all wrong." Took honestly a lot
of balls because I also felt bad. I was
like, I want to look like I want to seem
like I'm a listening leader. I want to
seem like, you know, I'm taking
everyone's, you know, ideas into
consideration. And when every single
person who's in leadership in the in the
business is like, you need to stop doing
this. You need to keep doing what works.
I was like, you're all wrong. I'm going
to keep doing this cuz I know it's the
right thing. And so sometimes you have
to do that. And this is one of my
favorite memes ever. Can you pull up
that meme that has the It's like, yes,
you're all wrong. It's like one of my
favorite memes. It's like here's a meme
and I probably love this meme. It's
probably my single favorite. It's not
really even a meme, I guess. I mean, I
just think it's a visual, but like I
think about this one a lot is that
sometimes you just have to be that guy
and be like, "Yeah, you're all wrong."
Number eight, hold yourself to a higher
standard. Now, this is different from
raising your standards in terms of what
you believe is possible. This is taking
that same idea and applying it only to
yourself. So, the first example I talk
about is the universe. is like what do I
believe is possible in the universe
versus what I believe is possible about
my behavior and I think the world has
gotten incredibly soft especially in the
west and so self-love if there is such a
thing isn't a wine and spa day it's
holding yourself to a higher standard
than anyone else does I think self-
loveve is doing whatever you can to
bridge the gap between who you currently
are and who you believe you can become
and so the voice inside of your head
that's never satisfied with your
achievements isn't your insecurity it's
the part of you that knows that you can
do more. So don't listen to people who
are like ignore that that little voice.
It's like no that little voice is
knocking on your head being like dude
you can do better than this. Like we
don't have to accept this reality like
we can be more. And so if you think
about how how humans learn things,
right? The primary way of learning is
through modeling. We see other people do
things, right? And then we do them,
right? We actually get feedback from
from doing it ourselves. And so if you
want within an organization to inspire
everyone else to go to a higher
standard, then you have to hold it
yourself. And I would say that I'll give
you two very tactical examples. So Leila
had this realization that she wanted
everyone in the company to dress up
more. She said she saw people who were
showing up on Zooms like they just got,
you know, got out of a bomb shelter. I
mean, who knows? Whatever. And she she
was like, "Man, these, you know, these
these people just look like they're just
rolled out of bed." And then she looked
at herself in the mirror and she was
like, "Well, I'm kind of just like
wearing sweats and have no makeup on and
like all this stuff." And so she started
dressing up and like putting makeup on
and just like, you know, looking
presentable. And all of a sudden, she
didn't even say anything. The rest of
the company started doing it, too. And
if you're curious, how do they deal with
how I dress? She lets everybody know
that this is actually a uniform for me.
And so I am in uniform. It's just my
uniform is different than theirs. Just
FYI. So the second example is that at
acquisition.com, I would say just about
everyone works six days and probably
half the company works seven days a
week. Now, anyone who hears that, of
course, all the super soft people,
you're fine. You can comment there if
you want to, but we're trying to win.
And so, the reality is the people who
are on the other side of the globe who
are fighting to beat you are happy to
work 7 days a week. No problem. Also,
7-day work week completely manufactured
as of like the 19 like 40s, right? Like,
this is a a new human concept. This
isn't like, oh my god, how are these
people surviving? This like you're going
to be okay. Now, let me tell my story
now that we've diffused the the the
weakness bomb. Many people work that
way. Why? I work and Leila work. And so
if you want to see a certain behavior
exist within your company or your
surroundings, best way to get that to
happen is to model it yourself. And so
this is just as true with an
organization or it is with a team or
even as it is with you and a spouse.
Like if if I want Leila to start doing
something, one of the easiest things is
just start doing it for her. And the
nice thing is that you don't even have
to have the conversation. It just starts
happen. And then as soon as it happens,
reward, reinforce the behavior. Yeah.
And some of you guys have seen me write
this little in a bunch of places. And uh
I talk about being one of zero. So I'll
tell you where that came from. So at the
book launch two years ago, one of our
things when we were building out my you
know brand was one of one content which
is like only make stuff that we can
make, right? Don't make stuff anyone
else can make. And we kept that. And as
we approached the launch, you know, it
got cooler and cooler and we were like
we're going to give away even and then
eventually was like we're going to give
away it all, right? And so believe it or
not, the giving away at all was like a
surprise that like half my team didn't
know about either at the launch. So it
was like actually super fun for me in
the background. But when that happened
and everyone went nuts for it, they were
like, "Dude, that wasn't even one of
one. It was one of zero." It wasn't just
doing what only you can do. It was doing
things that you didn't know you could do
yet. Doing things that you didn't know
were possible, but you believe are
within your potential. And that's why I
love one of zero so much is that like I
want to live a one of zero life. Not a
life that only I can live, but a life
that best version of me that can do
things that I can't do yet. I want to
live what that man would live. And so
that is why I think it's so key to be
able to hold yourself to a higher stand
and be able to do that for a long and
enduring basis because it's the only way
that you're going to achieve what you
ultimately want or at least what you're
capable of. Now, let's talk about
reality. Number nine, accept hard
tradeoffs. There is no perfect way to
live your 20s. You either live them up
and become an underskilled 30-year-old
or you work them up and become an
underlived 30-year-old. You just have to
figure out which you'd rather be, accept
the trade-offs, and know that there are
no doovers. So, in my experience, I've
met far more people who were
dissatisfied with their live at Up 20s
than those who regretted their work at
Up 20s. Because in your 20s, most of the
time, you don't really know what you
want. But what you need to do to grow
and move forward is usually pretty
straightforward. So, you take the known
path and along the way, you gain
perspective on what actually matters to
you. And often you realize that there
are far fewer things that truly matter
than you originally thought because
living it up in your 20s might have just
been chasing your mom's dream or your
friend's dreams only to wake up in your
30s and realize you didn't live it up at
all and you didn't work it up either and
now you have neither. And here's another
hard truth about this. What you believe
is going to be your live it up in your
20s, your 40-year-old self doesn't value
any of that. But your 40-year-old self
absolutely will value the skills that
you acquired in your 20s. because the
skills will stay with you and will
compound with time. But I want to be
clear. I don't say you should or
shouldn't do anything. You can do
whatever you want. This is just one
man's two cents if you're dissatisfied
with your current. But I remember there
was this moment when I had six gyms and
I knew what I was going to do to get to
10 locations. I ended up flipping the
model and doing something else. But when
I realized what it would take to go from
6 to 10, I remember I made this video
where I publicly basically was just
like, "Hey, I'm working a lot right
now." and I was working basically like
612s and I still kind of like took
Sundays and I used to watch the Ravens
and I looked at what little time I had
left in my week and I was like well am I
willing to give up the Ravens which is a
football team for those of you guys who
aren't in the US and you know fantasy
and you know Netflix series that I watch
am I willing to give up that to get to
10 locations and I was like yeah I'm
willing to give that up for 10 locations
and so I made the trade. Some of you
aren't willing to give up wreck
dodgeball or, you know, beers with the
boys. And I don't think like if if
you're not, great. Just make sure that
you're doing it for the trade-off that
you know you're actively making, right?
If you're doing it by default, right? If
you're watching your TV series, then you
really are like, "No, I would prefer to
have this TV series than Michael, then
dude, more power to you." The thing is
is that most people make unconscious
traits. They accept the trade-offs. So
once you've accepted the trade-offs, the
next one is you have to be willing to
look like an idiot. You just have to be
willing to look like an idiot while you
figure it out. Because once you figure
it out, everyone else looks like an
idiot for doubting you. The easiest way
to lose in life is to avoid looking bad.
So Sam Alman had this little blog post
that he made about the power of being
misunderstood, but he basically posited
that you should trade being short-term
low status for being long-term high
status, which most people seem unwilling
to do. And a common way that this ends
up happening is by eventually being
right about an important thing that most
people don't agree on. But the key thing
is that fundamentally you see something
other people don't see and they don't
believe what you see and so they bet
against you. And all asymmetric returns
in life come from betting against
conventional wisdom. But conventional
wisdom is usually right. And so you have
to be willing to bet big. And the thing
that's unproven is you. And so of course
it makes sense for them to bet against
you because conventionally they'll be
right. But you're n equals 1 and you
have a much longer history with you than
they do. And so you actually have an
asymmetric information advantage against
everybody who bets against you is that
you know you more than they do. And so
you know that if you say you're going
all in, you're going all in because
opportunity only looks like opportunity
looking backwards. Today it looks like
risk. So a couple final thoughts. When
losers go through hard, they think poor
me. When champions go through hard, they
think poor everyone else is going to try
and catch me because they're going to
have to go through this too and they're
not going to make it. And so despite all
the hard that you're going through, you
just have to believe with all your heart
that you're going to make it. Because
the thing is, as long as you keep
trying, you are making it. And one of
the things that I've learned about
success to the degree that I can even
say this is that you become successful
the moment you decide you are. Because
there's always going to be another
goalpost. And the thing is is that your
current self today is living a life that
your past self once dreamed of. You've
accomplished goals that you said would
make you happy. You've accomplished
things that you said would make you
successful. And so success is very much
in the eye of the beholder, including
your own. And so that means that you can
both be successful and be dissatisfied.
They don't have to be mutually
exclusive. And I think that's okay.